relier versa chantier à l'aéroport
d'orly en 30 minutes c'est le défi que
tentent de relever la ligne 18 lancée
par la société du grand paris en 2011
le projet fait actuellement l'objet
d'une enquête publique depuis le 21 mars
2016 jeudi 14 avril dans le cadre de
cette enquête
une réunion publique était organisée à
guyancourt pour recueillir les remarques
des habitants
c'est un exercice de démocratie
participative
ce n'est pas la société du grand paris
qui organise ces réunions publiques
c'est la commission denquête ce n'est
plus dans le cadre de la concertation
est donc le but c'est que le public
puisse s'exprimer donc on laisse un
large temps si vous voulez aux questions
réponses et ils ne sont qu'à observer
les questions réponses et ensuite dans
notre rapport nous analyserons ces
questions réponses la commission
denquête a déjà recueilli plus de 2000
courriel une cinquantaine de permanence
sont installées dans les mairies des
villes concernées inquiétude principale
le financement des travaux
la profondeur du tunnel et les
conséquences écologiques
je suis venu aujourd'hui à cette réunion
parce que bien sûr le métro le tracé
initial on va dire j'espère qu'il va
bien changé parce effectivement très
très proche de ma maison demande de la
rénovation deux de nos transports sur le
rer b
qu'on mette un tramway et enfin il ya
tout un tas de solutions quand pas été
étudiée qui répondraient beaucoup plus
aux besoins de la population et ses cinq
ans que nous demandons les habitants ont
encore jusqu'au 26 avril pour faire part
de leur inquiétude à la commission
denquête après analyse des différentes
problématiques à les mettre à son avis
favorable ou défavorable
la décision finale reviendra au
gouvernement la mise en service de la
ligne 18 est prévu pour 2024